Oh God we are the best Jews my name is
Sarah and I grew up in a conservative
Jewish household I was raised in a
Christian and Jewish household so my mom
is Jewish which makes me Jewish my dad
is Christian I feel pretty good I went
to Hebrew school for like 13 years I'm
slightly nervous for these questions
because I don't want it to expose a huge
gap in my knowledge about my own
religion I'm ready I feel like I've been
preparing for this yeah the entire life
yeah look I am let's go like I think
it's like the Torah like reform
conservative and Orthodox I need even
need Hebrew school I don't think we
count the guitar hippie
reconstructionists
ha obviously Cola yeah yeah hot when you
say it
holla yeah I feel like I say it with the
hook yeah come on
this is gonna make my mother very proud
um Oh
Genesis numbers is one of them okay are
they like the Bible Exodus there's
another one that starts with D by L um
you know Leviticus numbers and then the
fifth one Moses that's on it that's
that's all I got - that's actually
really embarrassing I feel like it's 2%
[Music]
I knew the number 2 was in the
percentage so we should get points for
already killing thank you yes well after
World War 2 it had the word Gandhi
though like how many was like the 1880s
I feel like it was somewhere in
Switzerland okay you know what I'm just
gonna say 1945 just in case okay I was
right about Switzerland right I was
right about Switzerland Syria or
something I want to say like Turkey I
don't know why my gut was just like it
goes all right we're gonna go with
Germany hamantaschen are pretty good but
like if they're Italian food I would
expect them to be like a little bit
better it's at the tip of my tongue
man oh Manischewitz okay there you go
Wow Jewish delicacy finest wine in the
world questions that I thought were
really easy I didn't know the answers to
which was really embarrassing I'm
impressed
I am so impressed with us yeah maybe I
didn't ace this quiz but I still host a
seder every year I still am a Jew like
carries a quiz I'm very proud of like
yeah I get what schoolteachers are very
proud of me right now I hope
[Music]